SAR Hubschrauber
Wir sind mit unserem SAR-Team 365 Tage im Jahr
einsatzbereit für unsere Kameraden, aber auch für die Zivilbevölkerung,
wenn die Zivilen Einsatzkräfte nicht mehr ausreichen, können wir Hilfe leisten.
Jawohl, ich wiederhole Oberst, eine vermisste Person, großraum Grimming, westwärts,  Suchflug freigeben.
Jawohl, wiederhören.
Da fliegen wir einfach die Standardwege und schauen ob wir etwas sehen.
Und da suchen wir weiter.
Passt.
Ich als Bordtechniker habe grundsätzlich eine fundierte Ausbildung als Flugfahrzeugtechniker.
Vor dem Flug muss ich auf die Klarheit der Maschine schauen,
sprich, dass sie technisch einsatzbereit ist.
Ich mach dann gewisse Checks und bereite unsere Maschine für den Flug vor.
Unser SAR-Team besteht aus einem Piloten,
einem Bordtechniker und Notfallsanitäter und einem Heeresflugretter.
Es kommt vor allem darauf an, dass man den Hubschrauber in einer erhöhten Position
punktgenau manövrieren kann, damit der Flugretter,
der dann am Boden die Bergung durchführt, genau zum verletzten kommen kann.
Der Heeresflugretter ist ein Bergespezialist, sein Verantwortungsbereich ist vom Windenhacken abwärts.
Die Aufgaben des Heeresflugretter sind Verletzte, Verwundete oder Vermisste Personen
mittels Bergedreieck, Bergesack bzw. anderen Gurtsystemen aus diesen Umfeldbedingungen,
aus diesen schwierigen Gelände zu bergen.
Wenn ich als Flugretter dann unten am Boden bin, checke ich die Umfeldbedingungen,
schaue ob das Gelände absturzgefährdet ist, dass ich einmal eine Eigensicherung mache
und dann schaue ich wo der Patient ist, nimm Verbidungsaufnahme,
versorge ihn und berge dann mit den Bergungsmitteln die für diese Verletzungen passen.
Dann hole ich den Hubschrauber zu mir und dann gehts nach oben.
Meine Aufgabe als Bordtechniker bei Windgefahren ist es den Piloten genau einzuweisen
und den Flugretter punktgenau an die Unfallstelle heranzubringen.
Unsere Einsatzbereitschaft am SAR-Hubschrauber - 365 Tage im Jahr.
Erfordert ist natürlich auch, dass wir regelmäßig trainieren,
in ganz Österreich für alle Österreicher.